To Allah's meeting.
He says
the Adam
[Silence]
and it was and he there met
Adam Alaihi Salam the
forefather of humanity in the
first heaven. Adam Alaihi Salam
Adam Alaihi Salam saluted him,
conveyed a salaam to him and
welcomed him and testified to
his prophethood. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala showed him
the souls of all of the human
beings. To the right of Adam
and to the left. Those who are
to the right were of the people
of the right. People of
paradise. And those to his left
were the people of the
hellfire. After this, He was
taken to the second heaven.
Therein, he met Yahiah and
Asah, Alaihima Salam. Then to
the third heaven, and there he
met Yusuf Alaihi Salam. Then to
the fourth, in which he met
Idris. Then to the fifth, where
he met Harun. Then to the
sixth, where he met Musa Alaihi
Salam.
The
[Silence]
narrated with regards to this
great and pivotal event which
is the ascension of the prophet
the sheer number of narration
which have come from, you know,
many, many, many dozens, if not
more of, of companions, narrate
these things and some of the
people who learned from the
companions and those after,
some of them got it right, some
of them may have, made a few
mistakes with regards to the
details. But Ibn Rahima Allah,
he mentions , in his opinion,
what is most authentic and most
correct with regards to those
events and anyways, if we were
to say he met Yusuf Alaihi
Salam in the fourth heaven and
Idris in the third, what
changed? Not much, right? It
doesn't make a big a big
problem. It just tells us that.
He met them. Both narrators
agree that he met Yusuf and he
met Greece. They just disagree
on which heaven he met them in.
So, they all agree on that but
they disagree on the on the
order of events and that's not
an issue which is a big deal
but when we look to the
pattern, the most memorized and
most well-versed from amongst
the scholars of Hadith, the
transmitters of Hadith, what
did they say? We find this
order of events is most
correct. So, add them in the
first. in the second, Yusuf
in the third, Idris in the
fourth, Harun in the fifth,
Musa in the sixth, and Ibrahim
in the seventh. There are
narrations which are taken from
the scripture
scriptures of Christianity,
scriptures, of Judaism there
are many stories about these
prophets that are common
amongst us.
Many of them are false,
incorrect. Some of them are
correct. We know are correct.
And many if not most of the
little details that we find.
You know, if we look into the
scriptures and the texts of
Judaism and Christianity, we
find that a lot of details are
mentioned. The details
really have no bearing on the
actual story and the parable to
be taken. we find a lot of
details speaking about
different prophets and
messengers. These details are
largely un sure. We're not sure
if those are things that Allah
told them or if those are
things that crept their way
into their book without their
scholars, being aware
deciphering which of it was
authentic from that which of it
from that of it of it which was
inauthentic and so the prophet
tells us that
the people of the book these
scriptures, these texts, these
details, these things that they
relate. We are not to believe
it and not to disbelieve it.
Meaning, we have things in the
Quran and Sunnah which when we
have something from the people
of the book that we are sure is
incorrect. So, the Quran and
Sunna is clear about that. We
obviously reject that, right?
Lot of claims for instance
that Suleiman and Dawud and Lut
are not prophets. In in their
book, many of them are not
prophets in Christianity. This
is something that we reject and
clearly in the Quran, they are
prophets. Or certain scandals
that happen with prophets and
messengers. We reject these
things. and then there are
things in these scriptures
which we know are
true not because of their
scriptures but because of our
book, the Quran and the Sunnah.
for instance, that was a
messenger and that there was a
flood, right? And that he had
an ark. We know these things
from the Quran. And so we
affirm them. We affirm them
through the Quran. We do not
affirm affirm them through
those routes. But there's
another type, a third type
where these this thing could be
true. It's it's not impossible.
It doesn't go against the
general principles of what is
true or false. with regards
to the prophets and messengers
and revelation. How ever
at the same time, we're not
sure that they're true. We're
not sure that it's, you know,
something that a prophet told
them. So, the prophet tells us
with regards to this type, do
not believe them and do not
belie them. Say Allah, right?
Now, in many of the books, of
Tephsia, traditionally, and the
books of history, you know,
books on the stories of
prophets and so forth. You'll
find that many scholars have
filled their books with their
respective works, of history,
or exegesis with.
These narrations and these
tales from the scriptures of
Judaism and Christianity. And
so if you read for instance the
story of prophets written by
Ibn Kathir. This book is is
originally from an expansive
book of history authored by in
that part in the first volume.
He mentions a lot of these that
he weigh at. as well.
many of these they mention a
lot of these yet. Now, these
scholars mention these things
just because they're trying to
mention everything that they
are aware of with regards to
this incident or this prophet.
It's as if they're saying, you
know, this verse right here, it
holds this meaning and as well,
the people of the book, this is
what they say about it, right?
That's all they're saying.
They're not necessarily saying
just because they wrote it or
documented it that they agree
it or they affirm it. They're
not saying that. They're saying
this is this is something that
was said, right? So, if you
read something from for
instance, the stories of the
prophets. You'll see that
Idris, Idris is considered to
be a prophet who was sent
before Noah, A you'll see that
there's other prophets that
aren't mentioned in the Quran
that were sent before Noah
and messengers and that they
had huge stories of you know,
thousands of revelations coming
to them and stories of war and
stories of jihad and so forth.
And largely, these narrations
are not authentic and when we
examine them with the pattern
of the Quran, we'll examine
them with the way that the
Quran speaks the style of the
Quran or we examine them with
what the Quran insinuates. We
see that they are not actually
correct. So, Idris Alaihi Salam
for instance if we look at
where Allah mentions Idris in
the Quran. He has mentioned
usually amongst the prophets of
Beni Israel, right? Which would
be after Musa Alaihi Salam.
He's usually mentioned in that
group, in that cluster of
prophets.
Likewise, we see that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala when he
speaks about Noah, he clearly
insinuates that Noor is the
first messenger, right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in the
he says we have sent revelation
to you just as we have and
those prophets that followed,
right? So, that wording there
is curious that prophets
followed Noah. They didn't
proceed him We see in Muslim.
The prophet tells us that Noah
is the first messenger to the
people of the earth.
There are those of us who have
read in these books
we'll notice stories for
instance about Idris. There's
one story that's floating
around that Idris Alaihi Salam
his time of death had arrived
and he wanted to live a little
bit longer. So, he wanted to go
up into the heavens and request
a longer stay in the Earth and
he was taken into the heavens
and when he reached the fourth
heaven,
The angel of death was waiting
for him there, right? And that
that was Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's destiny for him. These
are not authentic narrations.
These are not authentic
[Arabic recitation]
When the prophet passed the
sixth heaven which contained
Musa Alaihi Salam. Musa Alaihi
Salam began to weep.
And when he was asked why are
you weeping? He said, because
of a young man sent after me,
who more of his nation will
enter paradise than mine. If
you think about it, Musa Alaihi
Salam has the largest nation
after the prophet Muhammad
nation. We have Musa Alaihi
Salam, we have thousands of
years all the way because all
of the prophets that came after
him including all of that is
Musa's nation. He's their main
and chief principal messenger,
right? And the more people of
his nation that enter paradise,
the more of his reward that it
will be. However, when the
prophet was sent, everyone
after him became part of his
nation.
[Silence]
He says that after he passed
Ibrahim in the seventh heaven,
he was then showed the
the tree of finality which is a
tree of paradise. It's the main
tree in paradise. The prophet
described this tree and
the
[Silence]
Large vases and large pots He
described that it was engulfed
by a swarm. I don't you
wouldn't really call it a
swarm. I'm not sure what they
call it in English but a a
large
amount of golden butterflies
made out of gold and he
described it as quote changing
colors that he did not
recognize, right? So, colors in
paradise that are not colors
that are native to this Earth.
We haven't seen them. They are
colors reserved for the eyes of
the people of paradise.
Then the prophet was shown
which is mentioned in in the
Quran. It's been described by
the prophet as being
roughly above the Kaaba in the
Earth. If you imagine the
Kaaba, similar to it but above
it in the heavens and it has
two doors that the angels pass
through. So, as we
circumombulate the Kaaba, there
they pass through it. And
continue to pass through it all
through our, all through our
existence, until the day of
judgement.
But then
That's he was taken to meet
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and he was brought very near
Allah. Meaning the prophet was
brought very near Allah.
[Silence]
The that
Allah
[Silence]
and we have the the pen that is
writing that he was close
enough to hear this as it was
writing.
Allah
[Silence]
and every day and every night.
Some of the scholars, many of
them
that prior to the five daily
prayers, prior to Al Isra Al
Maharaj, there was a prayer but
it was usually just two raka in
the morning and two at sundown.
These were the times and this
is how the prophet with the
Muslims prayed before after
the five daily prayers were
obligated. And so at first
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded him with fifty daily
prayers in every day and night
rather than five And the
prophet returned with this
commandment. And back in his
descent when he passed Musa
Alaihi Salam. Musa Alaihi Salam
encouraged him to return to
Allah and ask for him to
lighten this obligation because
it will be too difficult for
the masses of your nation. Musa
Alaihi Salam tells him that my
nation was commanded with less
than that and they were still
unable to fulfill that and meet
that requirement. And so he
returned and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala continued to lessen this
obligation and lighten it.
Until it was five daily
prayers. Upon which Musa Alaihi
Salam still insisted that he
return and ask for a lighter
obligation. Which the prophet
replied that I am too ashamed,
I am too shy at this point to
go back and ask for any less.
Rather, I will simply be
pleased with what I've been
given and satisfied with it.
And the rest is to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so he
continued his descent upon
which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said I have affirmed my
obligation upon my servants but
I have also lightened their
load.
That my command is set and is
firm and so the reward of 50
for those who make those five.
So, for those who make their
five daily prayers, they are
rewarded with the original
fifty that was required in the
beginning.
Allah.